let's talk about alzheimer's there's
some recent information that i want to
share with you
that debunks this idea of amyloid
plaquing
causing alzheimer's there is a
whistleblower
professor matthew shragg md phd who did
a deep dive in analysis on a
foundational
research study that was done in 2006
linking
that amyloid plaquing in your brain to
alzheimer's okay now you have to realize
that all the funding and the studies
after that was based on this
study and if i'm not mistaken they
actually injected this amyloid plaquing
into the brains of animals and then they
they got dementia so that was a study
that a lot of research were looking for
to be able to continue their research
because so many studies at the time
did not
show positive improvement when they
tried to lower plaquing or trying to
block plaquing in the brain so in other
words this theory of plaque causing
alzheimer's just never took off it never
showed results and very unfortunately a
lot of people
are depending on research to come up
with an answer a cure a solution for a
long time and basically for decades
they've been focusing on the wrong
target a similar thing happened with
this cholesterol you know being the bad
guy this hyper focus on cholesterol is
the root of your heart problems has been
going on since the 50s all based on some
research in the 50s where they
selectively
omitted certain information out of that
study which gave you the different
conclusion that cholesterol was bad and
of course it also happened with this
theory of
depression being a chemical imbalance
they recently found that there's no
evidence showing
that
people who are depressed have a chemical
imbalance the very foundation that all
these drugs are based on now before i
get into what i believe is causing this
problem let's first talk about the early
symptoms of alzheimer's you have a
problem remembering recent events okay
you also have a problem trying to find
words
you have an issue with spatial location
trying to navigate through town without
a gps is very difficult and this relates
to a part of the brain called the
hippocampus which is
um all about
trying to locate yourself in in space
and that's the first thing that happens
with alzheimer's the hippocampus starts
to shrink
you also tend to get a loss of smell and
also mood swings
so to figure this problem out we have to
first
look at what we truly know okay
well we do know in alzheimer's that the
brain does shrink and it starts off with
the hippocampus we also know that people
who are getting alzheimer's are getting
younger and younger people who are 45
years old even people in their 30s and
even 20s are getting alzheimer's which
is
insane they also have found a high
correlation between
hyperinsulinemia high insulin and
insulin resistance
and alzheimer's and like i said before
they found that treating amyloid
plaquing just doesn't
produce results it's not fruitful and
they also talk about a risk factor
involving apoe which i'm not going to
get into in this video but all you
really need to know is that this is
related to ldl which by the way
is increased with this right here
hyperinsulinemia
and i'm going to touch a little more on
this in a bit
but
what i did is i started looking at
alternative theories to alzheimer's okay
and i looked through a lot of data and i
spent a lot of time with dead ends until
i found an alternative theory
that just makes a lot of sense because
there's a lot of additional information
that aligns with this theory and this
alternative theory is based on that
alzheimer's is a lysosome storage
problem now what is a lysosome storage
problem it's a little um factory in the
cell
that helps you
recycle
and clean up garbage so you have these
lysosomes in your cells you have them in
your neurons so apparently the garbage's
disposal recycler mechanism is broken i
mean if you had no way of getting rid of
your trash in your house and it started
building up
it would eventually leave your house
unlivable okay because the garbage the
toxicity
well that's exactly what's happening
with alzheimer's so in this little
lysosome which is the garbage disposal
recycler in your cells
you have the old damaged
stuff
garbage protein damaged proteins
goes through this little mechanism
there's over 50 enzymes
and acids that are dissolving and
breaking things down
okay and it spits out on the other side
these renewed building blocks so your
body can be very efficient and build new
cells
this whole process is called autophagy
so autophagy is a condition in your body
where you're recycling things so now the
question is
is there any data that backs this theory
up
and the answer is
yes
it just so happens there's a very common
mutation with a gene
psen
which
if there's a problem a mutation with
that gene you're going to have a big
problem getting rid of the junk out of
your cells okay and apparently the
mutation of this gene has for a long
time been known to cause alzheimer's so
that aligns with this theory as well
there's also a patent that i found which
i'm going to put all the stuff down
below which involves enhancing
the function of your lysosomes okay
there are certain drugs that can be used
to help improve or enhance this function
of the lysosome and so these are the two
drugs right here and this one decreases
neurodegeneration and this drug right
here enhances neurogenesis they're
rebuilding the creation of new neurons
now there are there any studies that
link autophagy to alzheimer's and yes
there is there's quite a few back in
these studies it shows that alzheimer's
is a problem with autophagy and then the
question is what would trigger autophagy
well this is where i'm going to go right
now but you have to realize that the
most potent thing to trigger autophagy
is fasting and there's a tremendous
amount of research showing that fasting
improves
alzheimer's okay so a lot of these
factors align with this theory so to
date i think this right here is the most
likely real cause of alzheimer's all
right so next question is
of course for those people that don't
like to take drugs because they're side
effects are there any natural
versions of these drugs that could
potentially enhance the lysosome well
yes there are a lot of things you can do
to enhance the lysosome function as well
as autophagy
and the first thing you should know is
what will induce autophagy is the
lowering of glucose that's a very potent
trigger so what does this lower glucose
thing mean it means low carb no sugar
okay so
the ketogenic diet that would be number
one number two fasting i already
mentioned this if i personally had
alzheimer's okay or or my wife had
alzheimer's
i would get them
well she's already on intermittent
fasting but i would get them on omad one
meal a day and every single week i would
do a 48-hour fast well you might be
saying what if the person's too thin you
know that's gonna be a problem listen i
would much rather have someone too thin
or myself be too thin
then get alzheimer's my mother-in-law
had alzheimer's and i went to the
assisted living home
where she was and it was devastating to
see
all these people
with alzheimer's
and their spouses coming to visit them
sitting with them
trying to communicate with them in fact
that's probably one of the most
devastating things that can happen to a
loved one
alzheimer's because you basically
lose your ability to think communicate
and this is tragic and of course when i
was there and i was watching what they
were feeding them it was snacks between
meals it was pure carbohydrates all
right number three i looked up and found
some fascinating research on how you can
use certain herbs that have effects
that enhance the lysosome as well as
increasing autophagy and the number one
thing that i found is curcumin that
comes from turmeric amazing properties
not just for
improving your cognitive function i mean
it's good for a lot of things but it
specifically improves and enhances the
lysosome which is fascinating number two
pine bark specifically pycnogenol in
pine bark has certain properties that
can help enhance the lysosome we also
have the herb thunder god vine
and green tea extract okay specifically
egcg has significant effects of
increasing
autophagy omega-3 fatty acids
specifically dha has great effects
increasing autophagy i also found data
on small chain fatty acids increased
autophagy as well and you get small
chain fatty acids from your microbes
your microbes make these fatty acids
from the fiber you eat i'm talking about
like salads so that fiber hits the
microbiome and then they make these
small chain fatty acids which are very
similar in chemistry to ketones
so going on the ketogenic diet reducing
glucose and also increasing these right
here increasing ketosis is the
beneficial thing
exercise is also another significant
inducer of autophagy so we want to
include that and then we have sleep
cruciferous vegetables certain
phytonutrients in extra virgin olive oil
make sure you get the real stuff and
lastly heat and cold
therapy so in summary alzheimer's is not
about getting rid of plaque
it's about getting rid of the garbage
that accumulates in the lysosome and you
do that by enhancing autophagy and
there's one thing applying all this
to a loved one or a friend that you know
but it's another thing to start applying
this information right away for yourself
and your friends and family to prevent
alzheimer's and for those of you that
want to learn how to do fasting i put
this video up right here check it out